HEISKANEN ONE-HANDS WILL BE SEN
OF THE
WORKED BACK FOR JANI HAKANPAA.O
POINT.
ELBOW FROM OKPOSO JOINS HIM.
FAKSA BEHIND THE NET.
HE'LL AND FAKSA.
NOT SURE IF IT'S GOING TO BE I
ANDERSON.
AS FOR OETTINGER.
>> Josh: THAT WAS THE YEAR
OLOFSSON
>> Josh: PAVELSKI
>> Daryl: WHILE THE FIRST PASS
IS EATEN U
SAMUELSSON, FEED FOR TUCH.
BACK FOR SAMUELSSON
CAN'T.
THEY REALLY STRUGGLE WITH
BENN HOPS OFF.DUMP-IN
AT THIS POINT IN HIS LAST SIX  E
CLEAR.
BUT IT'S BEEN PICTURE ESA LINDE.
PERFECT DEFLECTION BY BECAUSE
OF THE WEATHER.
FILLED TO THE MINDING.
>> Josh: THIS IS HIS TENTH STAR
INTO THE ZONE, DRIVE THE NET.KE.
AND FOR
AGENCY OVER THE SUMMER. TO CONT.
>> Daryl: MAN, THA